je cède la parole à monsieur le chef de
l'opposition officielle
brenda joffre la collaboration au
premier ministre est ce que le premier
ministre est ouvert à la tenue d'un
grand forum économique dès septembre
prochain pour doter le québec d'une
véritable politique économique
on attendait depuis longtemps cette
entrée de pierre karl péladeau en tant
que chef de l'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale c'est maintenant chose faite
sans surprise il entraîne le parti
québécois vers le haut on l'a vu dans un
sondage
mais au-delà de ça quel bilan peut-on
faire de sa première semaine à la tête
du parti d'achat michel daniel bonsoir
bonsoir
alors avant toute chose comment est ce
que vous avez trouvé cette première
semaine atterrissage réussi daniel moi
je verrais coûts et au niveau du parti
d'abord et il a vite ressouder ce parti
là non pas qu'il avait utilisé pas du
tout pendant la campagne à la direction
mais c'est toujours bon pour un nouveau
chef de rapidement rassemblé tout son
monde
jean françois lisée des lustres très
bien lui qui a choisi de ne pas faire de
vagues
l'unité du parti est assuré à
l'assemblée nationale aussi l'a choisi
il avait le bon taux il a choisi le beau
thème l'économie bon sa proposition de
sommet économique c'est pas la panacée
sa règle pas tous les problèmes mais ç'a
eu davantage de deux mètres dans une
bonne position de force et les libéraux
à lui dire non c'est eux qui avaient
l'air que fou là-dedans donc première
semaine afin première semaine premier
trois jours réussi entendons-nous là
dessus a sauf qu'il reste coi autour de
mes jours avant la prochaine élection
alors attendre wave ou michel vous
l'avez trouvé comment ouais ben écoutez
on a en une seule occasion de le faire
une mode très bien mauvaise impression
et monsieur péladeau a eu la bonne idée
de marquer cette occasion là là ça a été
plutôt bien c'est pas génial dans le
sens où on voyait qu'il lisait son texte
à marquer peut-être un peu de
spontanéité mais il s'est pas laissé
distraire et ça je pense que c'était
bien par
les remarques de monsieur couillard sur
l'instabilité politique et je parle même
pas des attaques contre 1 contre lui sur
sa mauvaise performance présumés comme
homme d'affaires etc
il s'en est tenu à son plan de match et
à cet égard là c'est une entrée réussie
maintenant c'est dur mais le jour comme
dit comme dit daniel et les deux
messieurs couillard et monsieur péladeau
sont toutes à tous les deux d'accord
pour dire que la question de
l'indépendance de la souveraineté votre
au coeur de la prochaine campagne
électorale à la c'est ce qui va se
passer on sait bien que monsieur legault
préféré que ce soit pas ici mais on
commence là tranquillement mais sûrement
trois ans de campagne référendaire à
toutes fins utiles et une rentrée
réussie mais quand même il a été vite
rattrapé par toute la question des
conflits d'intérêt avec l'achat
d'archambault par renaud bray d'achat
oui absolument et ses droits parce que
la semaine passée on s'est dit c'est
quoi son premier défi est certainement
ma prédiction que son premier défi sera
essentiellement de s'assurer que les
accusations conflit d intérêt ce ne le
suivrait pas pendant ces trois ans là et
on voit déjà qu'avec la vente
archambault à une aubry que déjà il ya
une autre question qui ce qui survient
et vraiment ça c'est un problème pour le
parti et pour monsieur péladeau
personnellement parce que il peut pas
toujours avoir repoussé les accusations
qu'il est encore impliqué dans les
décisions de quebecor ça nuit à lui
comme chef et sa nuit aussi son
indépendance et les enfants sont partis
de commenter sur ces questions oui parce
qu'il n'a pas été beaucoup question
l'assemblée nationale de tout de toutes
les questions que ça pose en fait les
transactions michel absolument pas il ya
quand même des questions qui se posent
sur la concentration de l'industrie du
livre les conséquences sur les
librairies indépendantes et évidemment
personne n'en a parlé
maintenant cette annonce là je pense a
été c'est bien planifié parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'était réglé avant
l'élection de monsieur péladeau à la
tête du pq qu'on a retardé cette annonce
là pour ne pas contaminer dans sa
campagne et une mauvaise annonce jour où
il arrivait à l'assemblée
d'abord on a attendu qu'il soit déjà eu
lieu et on s'est dit probablement faux
de l'annoncé ou plus vite avant que ces
actions soient mises en afrique du sud
parce que ça arrête encore plus
difficile on l'a très bien vu le été
consulté il y avait qu elle voit patiné
pour pour l'heure pour le voir mais le
problème va continuer parce que écoutez
monsieur moi devenir parfaitement raison
ne peux pas me prendre des décisions
d'orientation fondamentale et ça je
pense que c'est une décision assez
important sans consulter l'actionnaire
majoritaire alors il va en avoir
d'autres des grandes décisions à prendre
au cours des prochaines années
oui daniel est ce que ça salit un peu
l'image du parti québécois comme parce
que comment est ce que le parti
québécois va poser des questions quand
ça implique son chef tué il ya personne
au parti québécois il ya eu jean
françois lisée il ya l'air d'être entré
dans le rang maintenant il ya personne
au parti québécois qui a l'air de se
formaliser ou de s'inquiéter de la
position de monsieur péladeau a et ce
qui vient renforcer tout ça de vue ce
sondage 52 % des québécois n'y voit pas
de problème à il ya un problème il est
important que le parti québécois qui
s'est fait le défenseur de l'industrie
du livre beaucoup plus que les libéraux
je dirais pour être moi même un peu dans
cette industrie là et qu'ils ne posent
pas une seule question sur cette
transaction au sein de centre tout à
fait aberrant est-ce qu à chaque fois qu
une transaction touchant l'ancien empire
de monsieur péladeau entre guillemets
parce qu'il est en fiducie
on posera pas de question pour barbara
c'est monsieur péladeau est ce qu'on va
de sa françois legault kg fait mais sur
des considérations autres un commercial
à s'inquiétant des dés de l'areq le haut
du fait que les déchets est assurée ce
moment au québec
est-ce qu'on veut tous les ses soeurs
françois legault il ya quelque chose de
très inquiétant et un peu agaçant là
dedans
il va falloir que tôt ou tard monsieur
péladeau aurait accepté sur la les
filles du sis en droit de regard c'est
un grand principe intéressant je me
souviens qu'à ottawa et plusieurs pour
en témoigner
apa le martin nous disait que tout était
dans une fiducie sans droit de regard
on avait beaucoup de difficulté à croire
qu'ils ne parlent jamais à ses anciens
collaborateurs à ses fils s'est baigné
là dedans et c'est la même chose pour
monsieur péladeau il ya toujours
beaucoup de doutes mardi prochain
commission parlementaire pour étudier
justement cette question là
ce que c'est dans l'intérêt des libéraux
de trop attaqué par ailleurs monsieur
péladeau d'achat oui absolument écoute
pour les libéraux chaque fois qu'ils
peuvent mentionner ou attaquer monsieur
péladeau sur cette question ces attaques
non seulement son intégrité mais ça sème
le doute parmi le parti québécois
je suis pas complètement d'accord que
tout le monde est parfaitement content
que monsieur péladeau soit là qu'ils
sont rassemblés dans une unité qui le
désirent parce que le parti québécois ce
parti social démocrate parti avec une
veine anti capitaliste alors record se
rappelle que suite au choc mais oui
encore aujourd'hui à des militaires qui
sont dans cette position là monsieur
péladeau incarne une vision qui est très
différente de plusieurs de ses militants
là est justement ça l'était un peu
penser aux invités les grands méchants
capitalistes et tout ça c'est cette
hystérie au type là qui est suvi qu'on
parle de concentration de médias plus
que l'industrie du livre
c'est plus la concentration du média et
des médias et l'impact sur la politique
je pense qui serait un problème pour
monsieur péladeau
js que l'aîné on va voir ma la semaine
prochaine mais est ce que les libéraux
ont vraiment intérêt à faire son procès
là il ya 52 % daniel le dit jobs qui
trouve que la question est ce pas
important de finalement mais ça laisse
quand même il ya 41 % de gens qui eux y
voient un problème et il ya déjà une
bonne base de scepticisme que des
libéraux vont évidemment s'employer à
élargir
mais honnêtement je suis pas certain
qu'ils voudraient que le problème serait
il d'ici la prochaine élection
je pense pas qu'ils vont mettre monsieur
péladeau a dans une position où il devra
obligatoirement choisir entre ses
actions et sa carrière politique pense
qu'on va plutôt essayer de laisser
pourrir le problème si peu dire et faire
en sorte que ça soit que ça fasse partie
de la prochaine élection et que
laisser la population se prononcer là
dessus on aura le temps d'en reparler on
va passer maintenant ces dix jeunes qui
voulaient rejoindre les rangs
djihadistes
si vous on va écouter la réaction du
premier ministre on peut quitter
aujourd'hui à montréal et qui en a pas
bhl dans ce pays
nous avons ici un beau pays un pays qui
est démocratique libre ouvert tolérant
il n'y a aucune excuse aucune présent
pour un canadien de devenir un jihadiste
ou interdisent ou de devenir membre
d'une interview c'est tout à fait
inacceptable
un autre pays alors comment est ce que
les gouvernements peuvent faire pour
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire pour
empêcher les jeunes de se radicaliser
aujourd'hui mais sera peu à parler un
peu des familles il dit du bout des
lèvres que bon on avait on y prouver
quand même de la sympathie pour les
familles touchées mais c'est clairement
la lutte contre le terrorisme qui est la
priorité la loi l'ordre est ce que c'est
suffisant d'achat je pense que je suis
d'accord avec le premier ministre en
donnant des ressources additionnelles à
la grc et à la police pour combattre ou
pourquoi avoir l'intelligence et savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ces arrêtés
ces gens là avant qu'il quitte le pays
mais le désir de jeunes de s'impliquer
dans des mouvements soit terroriste
occultes ou autre c'est très très
anciens on voit différentes incarnations
maintenant c'est le terrorisme
djihadiste mais c'est difficile
d'arrêter ce phénomène je pensais plus
facile si on collabore avec la
communauté islamique c'est une autre
chose à faire mais arrêter les tous les
jeunes qui désirent de faire cela ça va
être quasiment impossible pour le
gouvernement de le faire parce que
monsieur apple ne parle pas beaucoup d
efforts de prévention et commander
radicaliser ses jeunes daniel
franchement ce que les gouvernements
qu'ils soient fédéral ou québécois ou
provinciaux sont complètement démunis
devant ce phénomène
ils ont aucune espèce d'idée quoi faire
c'est certain en ce moment que la
première solution ceux de les arrêter
c'est le rôle de la grc
tout le monde applaudit la grc socorec
absolument rien au lard et tidjane leur
enlever leur passeport mais sont encore
en liberté ils sont pas plus heureux
qu'il l'était avant pourquoi ils sont
malheureux c'est ça qu'il faut c'est ça
qu'il faut tenter de régler j'écoutais
ce matin marie amour
annick un dire c'est bien beau la loi et
l'ordre c'est bien beau la loi 51 c'est
bien beau c'est bien beau une nouvelle
charte de la laïcité que l'état
québécois en soit nous sur le plan
religieux etc
sauf que pour les jeunes qui fréquentent
les cégeps et qui ont envie de rejoindre
les groupes islamiques ça n'a aucune
espèce d'importance pas là dessus que
qu'ils vont faire tous vont prendre leur
décision ils ont besoin de comprendre
d'être mieux acceptée dans cette société
là ils s'engagent à savoir où ça
s'envoie tout ça et donner des objectifs
finalement si si si on trouve pas une
façon de les rendre heureux
ils vont vouloir partir au québec vous
emparez vous on attend toujours ce plan
d'action michel est ce que ça pourrait
aider la porte du gouvernement il a
promis que ça arriverait d'ici la fin de
la session web écouter s'il y avait une
recette magique
les pays qui sont aux prises avec ce
problème là depuis bien plus longtemps
que nous leur ai trouvés ils ont mis des
milliards dans la sécurité dans dans la
prévention et surtout dans la sécurité
je dois dire ça ça donne et ce con ce
constat on assiste aujourd'hui alors le
plan de monsieur couillard bon pour ce
qu'on en sait il y aurait deux éléments
principalement bon il ya son projet de
loi sur la neutralité de l'état des
accommodements mais ça c'est très bien
mais ça peut avoir avec la lutte contre
l'intégrisme ça sera compagnie d'un
pauvre un espèce de plans d'action à
multiples volets qui encore là c'est
bien beau dire on va travailler en amont
mais
dans la réalité des choses c'est assez
limité ce qu'on peut faire on a parlé
d'un observatoire bon c'est intéressant
sans doute monsieur couillard avait
évoqué et achètent des tantôt la
nécessité d'établir des liens avec la
communauté musulmane où il est encore à
ce qui en est sorti quelque chose qui se
retrouvera dans le plan d'action où
c'était simplement de l'esbrouffe
on verra mais je pense que ça passe
nécessairement par les communautés
musulmanes le problème d'intégration on
peut le constater mais au delà de seuil
et de les intérêts de mieux intégrer à
l'emploi et sert à détecter le mal le
mal de vivre de ces gens là je pense que
la communauté musulmane les familles
sont les mieux à même de le faire est
souvent et souvent et pour compléter ce
que michel si la communauté musulmane
était elle aussi démunis ils apprennent
à la dernière minute et c'est à ce
moment là qu'elle était qu'elle appelle
la grc demande à la police d'intervenir
donc il s'étonnait le méchant cul-de-sac
mais une dernière question rapidement
tâche est qu à une récupération par la
classe politique jeu pour faire avancer
certaines politiques mais je pense que
oui je pense que d autres problèmes et
aussi c'est que beaucoup ce recrutement
se fait sur l'internet ça n'implique pas
même la communauté locale nécessairement
musulmans alors c'est très difficile
pour le gouvernement de combattre ce
phénomène mais certainement je comprends
que ils veulent agir là dessus parce que
il ya une peur que ce phénomène se
multiplie effectivement oui de toute
sorte de crainte là dessus merci
beaucoup un vrai quoi verdon et dimanche
à 11h en coulisses du pouvoir emmanuelle
latraverse entretien justement avec lise
thériault la ministre québécoise de la
sécurité